c'est un scandale qui depuis 72 heures
agite les médias et les réseaux sociaux
pour la faire dit des dîners clandestins
des dîners luxueux dîner dans un luxueux
restaurant dans la capitale
la mise en lumière de soirées
clandestines organisé en plein
confinement par des figures de notoriété
publique commence vendredi lorsque le
journal de la soirée m6 le 19 45 diffuse
un reportage en caméra cachée sur les
coulisses d'une soirée clandestine
organisé en plein confinement dans les
beaux quartiers de la capitale
sur ces images que nous nous sommes
procurés une quarantaine de convives
sans masquer certains se font la bise si
les visages sont floutés les voit
transformé la journaliste précise que
l'organisateur est un célèbre
collectionneur
ce collectionneur mono mais se défend et
dénonce une pratique généralisée très
vite des internautes pensent savoir de
qui il s'agit et cite le nom de pierre
jean chalencon sur les réseaux
après plusieurs heures de silence par le
biais de son avocat monsieur chalencon a
reconnu être la personne interviewée
dans le reportage de m6 une question se
pose maintenant des ministres
participent tous vraiment à des soirées
clandestines chez pierre jean salençon
ce soir il nous livre sa vérité doté pmp
et oui vous aurez le témoignage de
pierre blanchard lançons dans un instant
vendredi dernier donc m6 a jeté un pavé
dans la mare en diffusant dans son 19 45
un reportage réalisé en caméra cachée
dans un restaurant huppé kandestin se
sont procuré des images d'une fête
payante ou une quarantaine de convives
sans masque se font la bise et peuvent
déguster caviar et champagne
regardez des rassemblements quotidiens
au lieu midi et soir comme cette fête
payante organisée hier dans un lieu
privé de la capitale
220 euros la soirée caviar et champagne
sur ces images que nous nous sommes
procurés une quarantaine de convives
sans masquer certains se font la bise
nous avons contacté l'organisateur de ce
dîner est légal ce collectionneur mono
mais se défend et dénonce une pratique
généralisée
j'ai dîné cette semaine dans deux ou
trois restaurants qui sont justement
ceux avec un teint pâle en 2010
alors ça me fait de son regret on est
encore en démocratie on fait ce qu'on
veut
alors on va vous montrer des autres
images un bien entendu est ce qu'on a
fait ce qu'on a comparé les images de la
soirée avec celle du palais filmer pour
visite privée sur france 2 regarde comme
cette fête payante organisée hier dans
un lieu privé de la capitale
bonjour bienvenue au pas la vision une
quarantaine de convives sans masquer
certains se font la bise
alors donc sans le citer ils ont montré
du doigt pierre-jean chalencon qui nous
donnera sa réponse dans un instant
gilles verdez pour vous est-ce que vous
avez des infos ou est ce que c'est un
scandale
alors déjà en 2015 donc pierre-jean
challans on achète le palais vivienne
pour 6 millions d'euros et en novembre
ils rencontrent lors d'une soirée le
chef christophe leroy tous les deux
christophe leroy qui avait créé des
restaurants qui est cité dans la sphère
là et puis qui était un peu en perte de
vitesse et donc tous les deux ils
décident de s'assembler ils sont réunis
par laurent amar et y crée des dîners à
partir de là viennent ces dîners
décembre 2019
ils réunissent des gens il ya des menus
à 160 euros il ya des menus à 460 euros
c'est très cher mais ça démarre avant la
bande des mitrons ils font ce qu'ils
veulent exactement ça démarre avant la
pandémie
oui le seul problème c'est que ça
continue après la pandémie ils ont
continué alors que c'est illégal parce
que fermer à organiser ces dîners dans
un premier temps pierre jean a démenti
sur twitter on répond dans un tweet
hausse je vous apprécie beaucoup
monsieur charles ans on lui a dit mais
si cela s'avérait vrai franchement c'est
honteux totalement faux et calomnieux
mais face voilà aux versions différentes
versions pierre jean salençon a réagi en
assurant l afp que son client l'avocat
du collectionneur a dit qu'il faisait de
l'humour quand il affirmé que des
ministres participer à de tels repas
pierre-jean chalencon grands
collectionneurs des objets de napoléon a
toujours apprécié faire de l'humour
c'est ainsi que quand celui ci précise
qu'il dîne avec des ministres dans des
restaurants clandestins il manie avec
brio le sens de l'absurde il ya quelques
semaines pierre jean salençon avait
d'ailleurs évoqué son envie d'organiser
ce genre de réception il l'avait dit
père je regarde mon il faut que tu crées
un club au palais qui viennent centre de
société sur la société ou du secret tout
pas mon cas avec des légendes la de la
société civile avec les politiques avec
des écrivains avec des journalistes avec
des amoureux de l'art
des gens de tous bords de toutes
obédiences et dans ce club deux fois par
mois on recevra avec mon ami christophe
leroy le chef de johnny hallyday et
d'autres chefs d'ailleurs et bien des
gens pour déjeuner ou dîner et donc on
fera que les produits français la
gastronomie française
alors oui en fait j'ai des idées dans
cette affaire il ya l'idée que des
privilégiés puisse faire certaines
choses que les autres ne peuvent pas
faire ça je trouve ça choquant en
revanche qu'on condamne des gens parce
qu'ils ont mangé ensemble par tables de
quatre ou cinq à quarante ont ce qu'on
se dise que c'est un énorme scandale
ça me suis pas d'accord sauf que on est
tous des en tout cas ce qu'il lui
reproche à son des hypocrites parce que
personne ne respecte les gestes barrière
à 100% mais non c'est pas vrai mais
c'est pas directement les yeux alors je
parle pas du côté luxueux ça c'est
encore autre chose et toi tu es votre
nom souvent contre je suis pas content
je suis pas con mais attendez ouvrez les
yeux des soirées à paris et dans les
grandes villes et à la campagne des
soirées des dîners des restaurants il y
en a plein ouvrez les yeux ou nana oui
mais alors d'habitude suis d'accord avec
toi laura chognot pas du tout d'accord
avec toi je veux dire pourquoi parce que
tu as une loi je crois le petit
restaurant qu en train de crever l'abcès
excusez moi je n'en je vais pas être
crues il se fait d être en or vous ai
dit il dit c'est on va mélanger un peu
tous les bords moi j'ai pas 160 euros à
m par personne non c'est ce que je dis
que vous devriez pas immobile et jean
louis avec ça c'est interdit non alors
le petit comme moi on va lui taper
dessus et eux parce qu'en fait ils
connaissent pierre maurice et ja que l'
os x 60 x est la même pour tout le monde
normalement je sais égalité fraternité
d'accord égalité je crois qu'en france
c'est un détail qu'on a vachement
oublier quoi mais non il n'est pas tout
c'est moi je dis qu'il faut taper sur
personne et koumassi ses anneaux là il
faut les tpe abbaoui déjà six ans parce
qu'ils servent à manger on devrait se
demander pourquoi en france aux tous les
restos sont fermés les n'a pas le droit
c'est à l'étranger alors s'il vous plaît
à dire par exemple il ya des
personnalités aussi qui ont été épinglés
grâce à des photos qui ça gilbert dès
lors on a notamment un chroniqueur qui
est relativement connu on a vu son nom
sur un carton d'invitation le 11 mars
ulysse gosset un chroniqueur paul y
voilà il ya son nom sur un carton à
dîner le 11 mars
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il est venu mais
son nom y figure on l'a vu est aussi une
photo avec notre alex goury on aime
beaucoup alex et voilà qu'ils kim qui me
donne sa réponse
alors pour faire clair encore une fois
si jamais tu parles de ce fameux resto
kandestin et surtout de
qui me retrouve associé à ce délire j'ai
fait pour la première fois de ma vie un
repas au palais vivienne en début
d'année un dîner à 5
et c'est vrai que sur la photo qui
montre et ils sont ils sont cinq un
dîner proue avec attestation sans chef
sans serveur et avec un plat à emporter
acheté au resto du bas pas exceptionnel
d'ailleurs c'est dans le respect total
de la loi
je subis un déluge dans merde depuis
hier je ne dors pas pour un amalgame
débile faits par des personnes qui
voient là et qui était énervé contre moi
comme je ne me dérobe pas la plupart
enlèvent leurs messages
après avoir parlé avec moi et compris
leur erreur je les en remercie pour tous
les autres je me réserve le droit
d'attaquer en justice toute personne
souhaitant remettre en cause ma droiture
légal et personnel voilà je n'en peux
plus trois petits points message d'alex
le boralex merci et je précise que du
coup c'était la première et la dernière
fois et c'est pas un restaurant c'est
chez lui et il me dit je n'ai pas payé
lol voilà mais il est extrêmement
touchée par cette affaire
faut pas les confondre moi j'ai déjà été
aussi dîné chez pia changement sont qui
est un ami et que j'ai eu tout à l'heure
au téléphone il ya des restaurants
clandestins paris il ya des boîtes
clandestine
chez lui c'est pas restaurant que l'on
espère là c'est juste un endroit qui est
dédié à napoléon y prépare il a fait et
l'organiser quelques dinars libre dans
un an si près par le bicentaire de
napoléon qui sera le 5 mai prochain et
donc ça se prépare ce quelque chose un
énorme événement dont il y consacre
toute sa vie d'un mois que je veux dire
sa honte mais à partir du moment où il
ya une addition avec un plaqué serbie
est un grand chef derrière pour moi et
pain mais là comme il veut l'addition à
460 euros ce n'est pas si pire jean
salençon c'est encore un autre est
encore jeune
les gens sont inhabitées mi journée ce
qui n'a pas fait pays encore maintenant
le restaurateur qui sont en train de
crever là depuis un moment
comment ça se fait que ce fonds mais je
suis là et il faut pas oublier une chose
c'est qu'à un moment donné à l'elysée
y'a pas une fameuse grosse réunion là où
ils étaient 200 ou 300 et après on a
indiqué que c'était une réunion et
antonio je sentirais comme je te dis que
ce genre de chose que tu dénonces je
suis là et aux ressources n'étaient pas
chez pierre chanson il ya d'autres
restant quant à lui préparé il prépare
un événement qui aura lieu le 5 et nex
disparités pour lorgner parce qu'on est
dans une dictature même si ça ne plaît
pas à mon cher ami qui a coté à partir
nos hôtes empêche d'aller te restaurés
comme tu veux j'avais parlé il ya un
mois et demi chez vous du passeport vous
rappeler non non non non non non
aujourd'hui le passeport il a été voté
pour l'europe et ça arrive en france
autre l'imposent donc je suis un
complotiste non pas du tout il faut
regarder le passé comme je le dis pour
voir le futur alors ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui on l'a déjà vécu la petite
phrase qui a fait le plus parler
dans ce documentaire notre reportage de
m6 c'est bien sûr sur le moment du
reportage de m6 où l'hôte de la soirée
donc pierre-jean en chalencon affirme
participer régulièrement à des soirées
clandestines et il croisait des
ministres on va revoir cette image et
c'est ça c'est le climax le principal et
les fêtes semaine dans deux ou trois
restaurants qui sont justement
d'ailleurs des restaurants au sud
d'auckland avec un simple nom de billy
alors ça me fait doucement rigoler on
est encore en démocratie on fait ce
qu'on veut elle pas les billets mais bon
on va mettre des lumières on peut donc
que sa bulle et heureusement qu'on peut
faire ça on a un côté ça serait ça très
grave
je ne pouvais pas faire ça non je sais
pas mais bon ça va ça fait quinze mois
qui nous emmerde
ça fait 15 mois que on en peut plus rien
faire moi j'ai pas eu un euro dead je
fais ce que je suis encore en transe
suis encore un citoyen normal pour qu'on
arrête c'est qu'ils sont malades les
mecs
alors justement il ya gabriella talent
le porte parole du gouvernement qui a
fait savoir par son entourage qu'il
était très étonné et ne connaît pas
monsieur chalencon parce que regarder ce
qu'avait dit donc pierre-jean chalencon
dans une vidéo juste après j'ai beaucoup
d'amis au gouvernement je connais bien
jean baptiste lemoyne qui est un copain
janvry esther j'adore oui au franck
riester bas roselyne bachelot c'est une
personne que je connais depuis quand
même quelques années maintenant et puis
j'ai pas mal d'amis dans les ministères
en poste de communication de chez notre
ami attal d'ailleurs doit venir dîner
prochainement notre ami attal jeu que
j'aime beaucoup
alors les a donc en réponse gabriela
talent le porte parole du gouvernement a
fait savoir par son entourage qu'il
était très étonnée ne connaît pas
monsieur chalencon et n'a évidemment
jamais participé à un quelconque dîner
au soir et il a aussi affirmé sur lci
qu'il ne croyait pas que des ministres
participent à ce genre de soirées
regarder je crois pas une seule seconde
que des membres du gouvernement se
rendent dans des restaurants clandestins
comme ça fait 10 par cette personne
anonyme je crois je n'y crois pas une
seconde
on demande aux français de respecter des
règles qui sont hyper difficile et donc
non seulement on doit les respecter
comme tous les français comme tous les
citoyens mais en plus de ça on a un
devoir d'exemplarité
parce que c'est nous qui demandons aux
français et moi je fais partie de ceux
qui sont sur les plateaux régulièrement
pour rappeler ses règles et rappelé la
responsabilité qu'on évoquait à
l'instant et donc évidemment on a un
devoir d'être totalement il reste
provenait rapprochables exemple là alors
on aura la réponse après de marlène
schiappa de bruno le maire également
géraldine est en tenue a raison c'est
catastrophique parce que quand il dit ça
malgré tout il ya un côté les nantis les
privilégiés le copinage ceux qui
connaissent on aura la réponse finale je
trouve que c'est dramatique à côté ça le
peuple à l'ailé lire les moins que rien
que non l'endroit de rien juste évident
effectivement vous disiez tout à l'heure
et éventuellement des amendes sur la
plage conti pique nique en famille donc
voilà donc je trouve que c'est
catastrophique et le problème de
chalencon excuse-moi janvier même si
c'est ton ami c'est que s'il dit vrai
c'est catastrophique s'il il faut c'est
catastrophique
dans tous les cas je trouve que c'est
catastrophique et moi je trouve qu'il
doit être sanctionné d'une manière
extrêmement ferme et radicale parce que
je trouve que c'est dramatique
nicolas pernikoff moi je crois que la
première fois sur le plateau il ya un an
je vais jetter mythomane quand il a
annoncé qu'il faisait quand même sur
france télévisions tout ça je pense que
dès que dès qu'ils voient la lumière
raconte des conneries mais qui sont
extrêmement grave parce que si aucun
ministre il a quand même jeté le doute
depuis 48 heures sur le fait qu'ils
aient des ministres qu'ils puissent
aller dans les dents des rays restaurant
clandestins et de l'autre côté quand
vous cherchez un peu sur twitter mais
vous voyez qu'il ya eu plusieurs soirées
vraisemblement mais ils on parlera au
palais viviane après ses propos quand il
parle bien sûr qu'on leur connaît donc
pourquoi il dit autant de conneries
pourquoi il parle comme ça pourquoi tout
d'un coup on est en plein délire de
conneries encore une fois de challans
millénaire c'est qu'on entend monsieur
attali est en train de nous expliquer
que le gouvernement doit représenter le
peuple français sans mensonges sans rien
et la raison j'ai fini et aujourd'hui
quand on regarde le gouvernement n'y a
pas une personne qui a pas des
casseroles aux fesses
d'accord ça soit pour viol pour voler
tout ce qu'on veut donc à les croire
comment on peut les croire juste un
tonneau renvoyant sur neuf cela c'est
pas pareil chapa à la ministre déléguée
à la citoyenneté qui a estimé que si des
ministères avaient participé à de telles
soirées devait être sanctionné oui ça
sera
jamais été dans un restaurant
clandestins absolument pas non non en
aucun cas vous savez nous on est là
d'abord on est enfermé entre guillemets
on est entre le ministère et le
parlement pour le projet de loi sur le
séparatisme et ensuite quand on se
déplace et manière très scrupuleuse avec
les préfets pour accompagner des mises
en oeuvre de politiques publiques
mais je veux dire que si d'aventuré il y
avait des ministres ou des députés qui
aurait enfreint les règles eh bien il
faut qu'ils aient des amendes et qu'ils
soient pénalisés comme le chaque citoyen
liste l'économie bruno lemerle il est
allé encore plus loin
il a même été jusqu'à demander ce que
les noms sortent puisqu'il n'y croient
pas regardé est ce qu'il ya un des passe
droit aujourd'hui de ministre pour des
dîners ce que vous veillez à ne donner
l'exemple a rythmé bien l'endroit pour
personne et je serais curieux que je
restaurateurs donnent le ton des
ministres ici bien informé que cela je
pense que tous les ministres sans
exception respecte la règle mais aucuns
estiment avoir droit à quelques passes
droits que tout ce monde
jean-michel la réponse de marlène
schiappa est ahurissante
elles disent et des citoyens comme les
autres folie's et une amende à 135 euros
s'ils ont commis cette infraction
maintenant on n'a pas le cas demi nonda
pour quel pays ils sont virés l église
est éminemment il a fallu qu'un
internaute lui signer à ça sur github
oui évidemment faux qui aussi qu'il
démissionne c'est complètement
hallucinant j'ai versé moi je lui ai dit
à pierre jean chalencon vous avez
déclenché une affaire d'état et qu'on en
dise et nicolas vous pouvez pas la
balayer comme ça tous les ministres du
gouvernement réponde à la question
pourquoi parce que tous les français se
disent effectivement ses ministres par
d'autres ministres ont fait pas de
politique ici les ministres français
sont capables de ça yahia verde le passé
et vous avez là bas quand vous ruiner
passé voyez ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
la sphère benalla on en est aujourd'hui
le drian alone est aujourd'hui recherché
attraper des comptes et le danger c'est
une chose impensable
ce que je trouve très injuste et que
vous dites il n'y a pas un mini scapa
des casseroles au cul mais en sont vos
passions c'est la réalité des faits mais
on est on est on veut rester dans le
débat surtout qu'ils écoutent oui mais
non mais on veut rester vraiment sur ces
repas excusé mal géré galons son
rétropédalage aujourd'hui en disant oui
finalement on doit rassurer dans un
instant jolie feinte ou docm mêmes s'en
moque il est catastrophique
parce qu'en fait on va toujours il va y
avoir une suspicion on va dire ils se
tiennent tous par la barbichette et
entraîne il est en train de dire mais ça
s'est jamais passé les ministres
non jamais de la vie et pardon mais ça
jette un discrédit sur les deux c'est à
dire qu'on a l'impression qui tient les
gens par là parce qu'en fait ils avaient
des problèmes aussi c'était c'était très
cher le palais visible mais lydie oui ça
me coûterait cher je m'en sors pas
financièrement donc on demande
on va trouver enfin - pardon je suis en
train de me dire finalement tout ça tout
le monde se tient par le bras michelle
c'est des histoires d'oseille et tout ça
il ya un truc suspect ben ouais bah il
ay la semiga message était fanny je veux
pas faire mon envieuse mara jeux etc
mais finalement je me dis quand on a de
l'argent on a le droit de faire la fête
ils ont droit
nous on est là ça veut dire hey tu
parles du bicentenaire de napoléon mais
qu'est-ce que je mens car moi j'ai même
à crémaillère à faire j'aimerais bien à
faire eh ben je vais pas la faire et va
lui il va le faire sous prétexte qu'il a
de l'argent et qu'est-ce qu'ils sont
comme serait ce qu'un membre ou pire non
mais est alors nommé à la landaise en
turquie rapidement je veux dire tu es
d'accord c'est pas garde after eight et
sous-préfets de l'oseille sous prétexte
de jets de losail bas je peux et si je
passe copie raison une amende se traçant
35 euros la main ils vont la payer ils
ont payé le menu 160 je veux dire je
prends pas ça me ferait un mais c'est
pas vrai il n'ya pas que les privilégiés
qui resteraient ctte barrière ya plein
de resto tout à fait normal ils ont
raison de le faire
il ya plein de fait avec des gens
modestes qui vont ils ont raison de le
faire aussi brad là dedans et pierre
jean charles ans on le dit lui-même
c'est l'absurdité de cette situation
donc tu agis lalami la ville arrive à
faire tout à l'heure on aurait dit un
épisode de faites entrer l'accusé donc
oui il servi les entrecôtes et oui enfin
c'est c'est absurde c'est ça aussi la
moralité de cette histoire est ce que
pierre jean chalencon dit c'est que
c'est complètement absurde
on en train d'accuser des gens parce
qu'ils ont mangé
moi ce qui me choque d'après après
qu'ils fassent des années déjà je crois
qu'effectivement c'est choquant mais la
loi est la même pour tout le monde nous
enserre moi je vous dis franchement ici
à ces tables on est plutôt tous à faire
attention
ses rivaux ont fait moi j'ai pas de
dîner oui j'avais juste peur que par la
maison ne m'attendais pas souhaité
bouleverser nos maisons ben foden et
vous j'ai pas de copain répond raymond
ces accords ont fait tous un peu
attention et lui dit impunément
oui bah oui j'en ai marre je vais je
fais 15 mai nous aider un avocat de sens
de faire comme ça si c'est à cause d'eux
mais comme ça qui nous a entendus moi je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec benjamin
d'ailleurs moi même personnellement
j'arrête je fait extrêmement attention
j'ai même dû dire à ma fille de partir
de ce qu'elle a 18 ans et elle rentrait
tous les soirs à 2 heures du matin 3
heures du matin donc j'ai chopé ma fille
j'ai fait ici t'es chez moi que tu as 18
ont pas je suis désolé on en plein kovy
jours donc la raison je n'ai pas de la
raison parce qu'il ya ton père qui a 71
ans et c'est très grave
oui mon frère il peut le show peut aussi
espérer pas en classe et tous enfin
heureusement et ma fille s'est fait
belle génisse je fais ce que je veux je
dis ok bah tu te démerdes tu vas chez
une copine ou tu te prends un
appartement également isabelle avec ce
moyen à 60,2 en général et pas l'hôtel
restaurant ici un lâche t-elle dit c'est
pas des coups de pierre jean sur nos
choix on à son droit de réponse puisque
on a la réponse
et en exclusivité de pierre-jean
chalencon il a décidé de sortir du
silence
il nous avait reçus nous a livré sa
version des faits sont ressentis tout
d'abord il nous a donné son ressenti
suite à la polémique
voilà et à ses yeux on a choisi un bouc
émissaire qui est pierre jean chalon 5
ou 6
je trouve ça ce d'autant plus scandaleux
la manière dont ces pseudo journalistes
19 45 que je pense être une sérieuse je
verrai avec mes avocats
j'avais beaucoup de risques progressiste
parce que j'ai beaucoup d'amis comme
stéphane plaza accepte mais j'avoue que
je suis très triste très triste de la
façon dont on m'a traité c'est une sorte
de guet-apens de coup monté je vais avec
mes avocats mais je pense que je vais
déposer alors on alors est un de ces
banques là encore plusieurs extraits
avec un gars jean pierre jean chalencon
il existe sur sa chance sur ce qu'il dit
là il dit ça parce que comme j'ai eu au
téléphone parce que il avait reçu un
texto de quelqu'un du 19 45 lui disant
je voudrais vous parler de tels sujets
etc
il a rappelé la personne qui l'a rappelé
n'a pas décroché cinq minutes ça rappe
on le rappelle après cinq minutes après
parce que l acceptation enregistré 100
l'unir déjà c'est pas une manoeuvre très
très sympa qu'on appellerait convient je
vous préviens tout de suite passé c'est
tout une interview je vous enregistrez
pas crois que ça n'appelle comme ça pour
rigoler comme y'a pas ils ont le crois
pas je pense à moi je ne sachant ni mais
je ne suis pas sûr aujourd'hui mal à
gérer ça pour l'argent dans la manoeuvre
qui n'est pas très loyal sans joie hier
je pense que le real au chalet mis les
ballons mettre les labels problème il
est que nous avons des ministres nous
avons des gens qui nous dirigent qui
doivent montrer l'exemple
d'accord je vais pas je veux pas non
plus écarté sur les salaires et ainsi de
suite
là on nous dit vous n'avez pas le droit
d'aller manger des restos et s'il
s'avère que c'est vrai comment voulez
vous qu'on les croie pour le vaccin
c'est la même mais tu nous la retenue du
lit à trop de lois faut pas la respecter
on en voit tous ceux qui respectaient
pas tu dis cette fois ci c'est de revoir
je suis dis simplement que si tu as des
gens qui doivent se montrer l'exemple et
ce ne sont pas mes yeux ne le fait pas
alors on va avoir des réponses de perdre
en chalencon et je vous dirai ce que
risque pierre-jean chalencon parce que
pierre-jean la maison ça peut être très
chaud pour les liens attention je vous
dis déjà c'est quoi
quinze mille aux amandes c6 est une
société c'est cinq fois plus donc c'est
50 prison et ses cinq fois quinze mille
ans mais il a dit laura rien
sachant mise en danger faute est obligé
de le défendre mais quand on a même
quand on a des amis si jamais il est si
jamais le le procureur de paris a ouvert
une enquête très vite pour mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui travail
dissimulé
effectivement c'est un an de prison 15
mille euros et il peut risquer très très
gros l'a sûrement il a ses automnes phil
harmer j'ai lu on verra si vous avez
vous imaginé il ya des ministres en
cause le procureur par youri lenquette
le ministre de l'intérieur dit je saurai
tout ça va aller très vite y mettre en
joue un gros curie là avec des gens qui
sont au dessus alors on avance on a
donné ensuite sa version edit comment
s'est déroulée cette petite soirée
exactement cette partie de soi don qui
la met à côté pas cette chouette jeudi
nous étions quelques cassettes des cas
s'il y'avait il y avait une éducation
qui se battent urbaine et sur l'ensemble
de la soirée qui s'est terminée à 22h et
commencer à 17h30 je fais mais à 17h30
locale a arrêté en avaient dressé des
tables c'était uniquement pour la
présentation que le bicentenaire de la
mort d'après j'étais cuisine depuis
quatre mois dont pas comment j'aurais pu
faire les switch est quelqu'un de gentil
quelqu'un de généreux et quand j'invite
les gens à dîner chez moi c'est moi qui
les invitent ce qui leur manque pas de
pays et regardez nous a donné son
ressenti suite à la polémique
bien sûr pierre blanche à lens ont
écouté ce qu'il a dit mais je trouve ça
très triste impression de convives
500 d'entre eux la révolution française
et vichy contient évidemment je n'ai
jamais organisé aucune soirées
clandestines surtout parlé des ministres
je suis très étonné en plus je suis à
lyon facture et je profite le cimetière
de prague et j'ai l'impression une essai
des chaires de me faire porter tout les
lycées connaissaient d'utiliser et je
n'ai jamais organisé deux soirées
clandestines avec quelques politiques
qu'ils soient hommes ça fait 15 mois je
ne peux pas travailler
je n'ai reçu aucune aide et je trouve ça
avait été demandée alors voici la
réponse bien jenson qu'est ce que vous
répondez exploded de sa réponse il se
fait c'est comme toujours il parle trop
saclay il s'exprime 'tweet' il fait des
déclarations la mort te blesses à leur
propre piège
sympa de nous répondre mais c'est ce que
je dis c'est de défendre c'est que le
premier de ce garçon sait qui passe son
temps à parler et à dire parfois des
bêtises ou pour faire une bonne une
bonne vanne ou pas et qu'à chaque fois
ça leur tombe dessus pour le coup je
trouve quelque chose c'est que il ya de
fortes chances que il porte le chapeau
pour effectivement pour beaucoup de gens
c'est possible c'est ce qu'ils disent
est un peu injuste car quitter le monde
sedin et c soit aujourd'hui en a plein
lui il prend pour tout le monde c'est
moi je trouve profondément remis à
parler après oui mais d'accord toujours
pas ce que lui en fait ils disent ça ne
me choque pas puisqu'il dénonce est
situé de la situation dans laquelle on
est et après sur les politiques
s'emparent les deux ministres parce que
ça je ne sais pas les politiques dans
les restaurants saint secret de
polichinelle ça fait des manières ça
fait des mois qu'on sait qu'à des
politiques de premier plan qui vont dans
des restaurants mais qui qui démarre pas
de ministre mais honnêtement à ma
connaissance mais moi j'ai entendu plein
de fois et j'ai même vu des politiques
aller dans les restaurants c'est
toujours comme ça on nous dira qu'il est
premier plan pour des anciens présidents
de premier plan
mais le canard enchaîné qui avait sorti
est fait cas d'un restaurant et bfm il y
avait fauché où il est tout le temps
fait partie
on n'a pas beaucoup parlé pareil oui moi
aujourd'hui j'ai essayé de savoir
franchement j'ai trouvé trace d'aucun
ministre non seulement chez pierre jean
chalencon mais modestement j'ai essayé
j'ai eu nulle part vend déjà mentionné
ça va piquer votre quart des gens là et
j'ai pas eu trace de ministres guillaume
dans des restaurants clandestins quel
qu'il soit après benjamin vous êtes
durée de chalencon parce que lui parler
s'exprimer on l'interrogé répond il dit
sa vérité interrogées déclarent il admet
il un pays déclara-t-elle j'ai fait
l'émission il dit oui bon je vois
jacques des ministres et d'une connerie
après indiana midi une connerie ça met
le feu aux poudres affirme émilie
drouinaud la batterie qui croient qu'ils
pensent que c'est pas une blague et
qu'en fait voilà il fait volte face
parce que ça peut ça peut partir en
cacahuète cette affaire je pense qu'ils
en rétro pédalage en avait quand même
peut-être des gens peut-être pas démuni
de premier plan même des gens peut-être
un peu quittera dans le vendeur du
malade mais forte du gouvernement et je
pense qu'effectivement il pas rétro
pédalage parce qu'il a vu que ça pouvait
prendre beaucoup trop d'angle arioui
c'est quelqu'un michel est quelqu'un qui
l'a eu au téléphone
c'est quelqu'un d'un peu fantasque ouais
c'est vrai beaucoup il fait du pire gens
c'est ce qu'on attend de lui c'est pour
ça qu'on le rassure et quand il peut il
en fait ailleurs on engueule voilà c'est
du pire jean chalencon qu'est ce qui
vous a dit ben voilà il m'a dit déjà
qu'il était prêt à partir de france et
moi namaskar faut qu aucune subvention
sans lui 90% des des objets ayant
appartenu à napoléon ne serait plus dans
le monde il a fait une exposition à
shanghai à ses frais et cetera pour
exposer dans le monde entier les objets
de napoléon qui reçoit aucune haine
aucune aucun pge et cetera
on lui tombe dessus pour une soirée un
peu près ce qu'il organise comme ça ne
fait pas de soi effet pays personne
c'est pas restaurant c'est les 460 euros
c'est pas chez lui lui l'a vite se
compteraient ainsi quelques crochets
il invite les gens qui cédera il fait
pas de soi et comme ça non donc il ya eu
qu est ce que vous dites quoi que c'est
il ya eu des et pourquoi procès pendant
s'acharne sur lui parce qu il a été mêlé
dans un sujet où effectivement il ya des
soirées clandestines appareils vides moi
je suis déjà habité de l'histoire en
boîte à paris où il ya des il ya mille
personnes ça coûte assez cher et dia
wifo l'alcool durant dans une posture
dans un immeuble prix là qu'il
descendait sous sol et la tat 300
personnes 400 personnes ça te coûte
assez cher est là t'as dj à la mode etc
on en est sûr est que tant dessine c'est
même tendance mais mon service a repris
1 dans les 45 qu'il avait vu il a réagi
il enfonce le clou
même si je sais pas si on à l'extrait
que j'avais demandé à la production on a
clairement envoyé cet après midi voilà
du 12 45 j'espère qu'ils ont bon on va
vous le montrer nicolas je renvoyais et
xorret jean jean michel tu peux pas te
dire des choses pareilles c'est pas
anodin il a quand même
il a quand même dit qu'ils avaient des
ministres la wii les manger mais enfin
dire n'importe quoi n'importe qui et
puis derrière il ne serait totalement
faux et calomnieux sur twitter à des
gens qui lisent mes chalencon ça va pas
vous ai pété un plomb quoi alors
attention il ya une enquête qui est
ouverte
donc il faudrait pas qu'ils aient 20 ou
30 soirée qui était fait depuis le 1er
juillet tu parles il ne faudrait pas
qu'il y ait 20 ou 30 soirée qui était
faite au palais vivienne depuis le 1er
février en tenant ce genre de tout ça
c'est juste envie de dire à tout le
temps c'est comme banal on l'attend
toujours la vérité ça sera la même norme
il y aura la vérité là restez sur
benjamin benjamin raison moi j'adore
gens comme tunis qui fait et très bien
challans ans et je l'aimais infiniment
mais en revanche il a dit la france de
ne pas ouvrir celle des mini c'est ce
qui fait que c'est un grand un scandale
d'état
et c'est il ya un soupçon de scandales
vite à cause de ça chez moi sur les
blagues il a retiré sur les milices par
ben il a retiré lundi c'est une blague
mais jean-michel moi aussi je suis ami
avec challans sont là vous dites une
contre vérité c'est pas vrai il ya eu
des soirées il ya eu des soirées
payantes avec le chef dont j'ai cité le
nom c'est le viviane club ils l'ont créé
il faisait payer ça jean michel vous
pouvez pas dire qu'apple des soirées
clandestines sa progression il faut dire
la vérité aux gens j'ai déjà six soirées
1 le 8 février
11 février le 5 mars le 11 mars tous les
soirs c'est soi et qui a retiré tous
deux sont instagram
aujourd'hui moi je peux résumer chance
que c'est plus complexe qu'on le croit
je pense que weeds organise des dîners
mais non pas avec des ministres oui
connaît des ministres il a peut-être
déjà dîné avec des ministres mais
rappelez vous il ya quelques mois
s'était encore l'égal de dinars y avait
encore des restaurants il ya ya cinq six
mois je pense que c'est plus complexe
qu'on ne le croit et que non il n'a pas
organisé des soirées chez lui avec des
ministres et dis pas ça il a dit même
s'il a retiré ses propos auraient vu des
ministres dans un autre restaurant faux
pas c'est un tout mais rien n'y en a dix
qui m'envoient et arrêter de dire que
c'est une soirée gratuite il ya le menu
les prix l'invitation son moniteur de
champagne car les plans du cref von
acier de saumon et caviar of mimosas au
caviar que beaucoup de cagliari parme a
cherché à lévis vienne jean-michel messi
et hâte de défendre votre ami il ya des
choses qui sont un des gendarmes sur
tours aujourd'hui à vous entendre petite
personne on vous dit vous devez faire ça
ça ça on vous empêche d'aller même
modèle et même au buffalo grill suis
désolé pour la pub ou autre et eux ils
se permettent de bouffer parce qu'il n'a
pas d'autre terme et nous on est là au
32 de tirer la langue
et ils font la même chose avec l'argent
tout ce qui est nous on nous demande de
faire des efforts avec la ceinture et es
augmente d'accord donc à un moment donné
il faut il faut dire les choses comme
elles sont
on est dans un pays de dictature même si
ça ne vous plaît pas c'est les modalités
mais j'assume mon beau jeu l'assument je
l'assumé
et quand j'irai mourir mettra sur ma
tombe j'étais j'ai dit que c'était un
pays de dictateurs aujourd'hui et
pourquoi ils partaient pas mais je suis
alors à l'envoyer vous avez bien fait de
me dire ça je prends je prends cyril
hatt et moi je suis en train de regarder
pour partir parce que voyez je lâche mes
biens immobiliers non mais attendez il
veux retrouver ma vie privée voyez vous
aurez peut-être du mans paris en dehors
instauré de gaza mais j'ai une question
jeu gg quelques biens dans un autre pays
d'accord et en france j'ai de la chance
d'avoir un bien je suis en train de
regarder que mon épouse et mes enfants
pour partir on a même regardé les écoles
oui je dois partir et je suis en train
de regarder
et plus ça va plus j'ai envie de partir
bah oui c'est ce que je fais ce que par
toute une chose qu'on ne pouvait pas me
retirer
je ne cracherai jamais sur la france je
paye mes impôts j'aime la france
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui je suis
triste de voir ce qui se passe si vous
cracher ou dit chez les chairs et crache
pas d'arrêter
je penserai à tour moi j'en vois le menu
donc riche est l'arrêt court derek était
prévu qui n'a pas eu lieu
bonne émission s'il vous plaît mais
c'est vrai qu'avant
-participation 220 euros c'est même mon
raymond qui mélangera l'envoi recteur
san roque alors si en plus il paraît que
l'abbé la brdp va l'entendre le mettre
en garde à vue par la priory avalant de
son portable et perquisitionné ne sont
pas les prendre son ordi tout sera
épluché vous voyez pierre-jean il s'est
mis dans un sacré merdier sacré merdier
oui on va pas se mentir il s'est mit qui
viendra de nous en parler mais c'est
vrai scandale de boissons 1% histoires
anecdotiques 30%